no matter where you are in the world no
matter who you are you need food to
survive
that's just truth there's some people
out there that claim that they can get
by with just
breathing energy in which i don't know
about that one
but i'd rather just have food if i had
to choose between getting my energy from
breathing it in like plants
or eating plants i would rather eat
plants specifically in the form of a can
with green beans either way this is a
long way around to get to a point of
soldiers need food when there's soldiers
out in the field there ain't no apple
tree to pick
there ain't no
grocery store you can't order a pizza
when you're in the middle of a war zone
okay so what you need
is you need what's called an mre which i
think stands for meal ready to eat
but i'm sure there's different varieties
of it
this probably should have been more
dramatic rachel you make this more
dramatic
anyway
there's a lot of technology that goes
into this a surprising amount because
number one
mres have to be meal ready to eat us
government property commercial resale is
unlawful
how to do this commercial resale is
unlawful i got this
from a soldier he said it fell off the
back of a truck it wasn't commercial
it was illegal so i've actually got a
few different varieties of this we got
chicken chunk we got tuna chunk
lite water packed
lemon pepper and we have elbow macaroni
and tomato sauce
not what i was expecting to come after
elbow macaroni this is going to be a
you choose your own adventure review
where you guys get to choose
if you want the chicken chunks comment
if you want
the tuna chunks add this video to your
favorites remember when that was a thing
that's a thing
uh if you want the elbow macaroni in
sauce tomate
subscribe if you want the beef ravioli
in meat sauce
hit the like button comment favorite
subscribe like
okay cool we're now tabulating your
results
oh yeah got it nailed it uh beef ravioli
and meat sauce so i've actually
never had an mre before i've bought them
before just casually just because i was
curious but i never actually ate them
because i wasn't brave enough or
i forgot about it and they just rotted
away which is weird because i don't
think these
things are supposed to rot i think these
things are supposed to last a long time
that's the weird thing about food right
some food
you you get food and it becomes not food
right away
like you get it even in your fridge it
goes no food and but
there's other foods that you put in
pantry no fridge it's stay
food long time if you get this though it
stay food
forever okay they have caveman soldier
mre that they dig up and they eat and
it's like oh still food
how is that still food you know food go
bad sometimes but food no go good
all time i'm gonna try this i'm more
excited about the flameless
heater in this thing oh looks like a med
bag i've never seen a med bag before but
that's what smells like nothing
i bought this too because on the back of
the truck that i bought it from
the soldier who gave this to me
non-commercially said that people
frequently buy this together
and i thought sounds pretty good to me
anyway i better hurry up how long has it
been
[Applause]
oh that is a nice spoon no fork
though
i don't know why i couldn't have been a
spork but this is just a
i guess if you're you know in war and
you're in mid meal you want to be able
to actually like fight so you know this
could definitely double as a weapon
do not over fill that's right this needs
water military rations are good
performance meal food gives you energy
the more energy you burn the more food
you need
you are more active during field
training deployment and combat than in
garrison
you need to eat more and drink more
water or other fluids in these
situations
when you don't eat enough you beat your
body's energy needs you lose weight
this can lead to a bottle of body fluids
and degrade your performance in field
you need
three meals per day one meal ready to
eat contains 1200
calories hot beverage bag
a bag for my beverages i don't know if
i'm gonna need this but i'm gonna just
hold on to that for a second
everybody hold on i'm gonna get a big
old mug of water
i have water okay i actually don't know
how to do
any of this this is the beef ravioli
chocolate banana nut muffin top tooth
chocolate banana muffin top nut
help turkey nuggets orange flavored no
fruit juice okay
well that's good cheese spread and white
wheat snack bread
i don't know why i was hesitant to open
that that
[Music]
i love that they shaped it like bread i
mean it is bread but i love that they
shaped it like a loaf of bread you know
there was probably some psychological
analyst
that was like hey soldiers will love
this
even more get a little morale boost if
it looks like a slice of bread that they
got from a grocery store
remind them what they're fighting for or
a really wide penis
okay uh bread bread
do i need like more water i don't know
it's a lot of pouches i'm just gonna say
that right out loud
it's a lot of pouches vapors released by
the activated heater contain hydrogen a
flammable gas do not place an open flame
in the vapor
vapors released by activated heater can
displace oxygen when 10 or more heaters
are used inside a vehicle or shelter
ensure the ventilation system is
operating or a top hatch or door zone
water leakage can burn and cause a cold
weather injury use caution if carrying
activated teeter and pocket after
heating the heater bag and mre pouch
will be very hot
use caution when removing the mre pouch
from bag discard heater and bag after
use do not drink the water remaining in
the bag or use it in food items
what the hell do i do with you here's
the complicated instructions you get all
that cool
uh i'm gonna wing it how many soldiers
have said that
open this is the ravioli
and then i put water up to a fill line
lean the heater up against a rock or
something no
put up against a rock or something i
don't know put it up against a rock or
something
what do i have that's something i don't
know all right let's freaking go for it
baby i ain't here to foot around
i'm here to eat
do not overfill i overfilled oh i
overfilled put it back but
oh they said not to drink it i
overfilled it i'll just get more water
later
hold on top of mre put into sleeve
sleeve okay i got it up against the rock
or something so i do appreciate
by the way there's a lot of effort that
goes into just making this so that
soldiers can have a hot meal that
psychologically
is very important if i'd imagine going a
long time without just a
warm meal that would affect me
how long am i supposed to wait for that
i'll probably know
anyway just like a warm meal you know
people take it for granted this is
muffin top
very squished but smells delightful
well okay hang on a second
starting to smell not so good turkey
nuggets that looks
delicious that looks delicious look at
that
i don't like that i can smell it through
the plastic that's probably not a good
sign but
hey ain't no i can't open this
i'm not a
all right no bacteria getting through
that so we got the um
nuggets yeah they smell okay
ooh yay oh
i remember thanksgiving dinner this is
definitely the color of the turkey that
i remember eating dark meat for me
please and then cheese spread which i'm
guessing goes on the bread
pepper sauce made with tabat okay dude
tabasco pepper tabasco thought
that it looks like it opens i'm guessing
it doesn't open
very tough i think that's oh we got the
orange
water so tang
i've mentioned tang a lot in these
videos for never really drinking
tang well
that's a sweet treat that can't be beat
you know what i'm saying but i like the
idea just like powdered drinking it in a
hey tastes fine okay let's see if the
ravioli is done i don't know how to tell
i guess it'll feel hot are you warm oh
it's very warm
i don't know if it's quite ready yet so
i'm going to start with the bread
because that's what i opened first so
bread and cheese
bread first tough bland
doesn't taste a lot like bread there's a
weird sweetness to it
and i don't like that also there's a
slight taste of i thought
that the bread i didn't like in the
cheese i didn't like might combine to
something i
i like but it turns out two negatives do
not make it positive in that case let's
go skip ahead to dessert first
that's not bad the banana not quite
banana
it feels like untapped potential you
know you know it feels like that kid
who went through school in all the
gifted classes and like went into all
the
like exceptional classes and did really
well without even really trying a lot of
effort and everyone told the kid like oh
hey you're doing me something
someday you're really smart you're
really clever you're really going at it
but they never replied themselves after
that because they got in their heads
that they didn't need to
because of all this praise and it kind
of got to them and as things got harder
they never really knew how to cope with
it because they didn't really know how
to
put in the effort in the first place
they were so used to having things be
easy for them to be
to shine through and it's not that they
got dumber it's just that their
expectations of themselves were so high
that they expected to be able to pass
flying colors without any effort but as
things got harder and they needed to put
in more effort so the
effort needed to scale proportionately
to where they were and yet they kind of
drifted and then they didn't really know
what they were doing with their life and
they
they they felt like you know if they
weren't going to get it on the first try
they might as well not try at all and
they kind of like faded out you know
it's not that they
like ended up like completely
downtrodden and all they just never
lived up the potential
it was there but never acted upon
you know what i mean turkey
of hmm what pepper you done i'm gonna
guess yes
need mre to ensure uniform temperature
yeah this definitely ain't uniform
temperature that's for sure okay
i'm pretty sure i did this wrong
okay this is supposed to be ravioli
remember that
that's what this was supposed to be
[Music]
okay so i must have done something wrong
there because this did not heat evenly
but it does kind of look like ravioli
and it does smell kind of good still
cold like someone's cold but hey
much like my green beans i can eat this
straight out of the can if i'm eating
some chef boyardee or something like
that which is what i'm expecting when i
take this bite
you know that
is not bad it's not the greatest thing
in the world but
it's nowhere near the worst this is fine
this tastes normal
if you told me that this was like some
off-brand ravioli in the can i'd
believe it and i'd be fine with it
because it's quite good
oh that's quite good all right i need to
clean this out because i need to reuse
it i only brought the one i
should have brought more now pretty good
that sets the standard pretty low
it's okay you know it's it's all right i
imagine myself
out in the middle of nowhere i'm hungry
i have this to eat
it's nice it's all in one you got your
spoon you got all your things it heats
itself if you got some water you're good
to go which hopefully you have some
water if you don't have any water
you got to make it with piss and i don't
imagine that's good for anybody probably
very unpleasant especially if the smell
isn't you're in a closed container like
he was talking about and you got no
ventilation because you can't let anyone
know where you are
you got to make it with piss i guess it
might work i'm going to leave that to
someone else to try that but
just saying that i this is what i
imagine all right but we're going
somewhere else because
america is not the only military in the
world and all soldiers need to eat at
some point in some time so we're going
straight over to
russia russia russia i can't even come
close to reading russian so i might do
this completely wrong
also look how freaking big this thing is
that's huge i actually don't know if
this is gonna also have like flameless
heater or stuff like that i
imagine it will this is resealable what
the hell
this is a ziploc whoa it's reassembling
this
oh it's a box
[Applause]
it's probably like four in one
no no i just realized i won't be able to
read any of this
so i really don't know what this says
you've got
this stuff you've got apples
what is this oh god no i have to
burn it we've got this
this is going to be a mist this is going
to i'm going to die we've got it's like
tea or something tea bag
tea we have this thing
we have tub of meat
i think more tub top of thing we've got
tub of thing
oh we've got a spear
they really do have a spoon spear got
three spoons can you attach this to your
spoon spear
no i gotta admit this spoon very flimsy
this ain't near the kind of wumpage that
you can get out of this spoon here
nah nah oh see just cracked so clearly
there are some crackers here so i'm just
going to go ahead and try these as they
go i'm not going to try to lay this out
because there's no way i'm going to be
able to do this crackers
once you get past this exoskeleton
that's a decent cracker okay so i got
this weird flaming thing
there's a smell emanating from somewhere
this one doesn't have a picture
i think it's coming from here kind of
smooshed kind of leaking
i don't know if i dress this one
is that how oh look it's like a little
uh
little uh little table and um i'm
thinking these must be solid fuel
tablets this feels like a bad idea oh
that feels like a bad idea so
you take the tub of i'm guessing meat
let's just try this one i'm assuming you
open it first otherwise it might explode
upon heating let's see what that oh that
looks
good oh
oh that that doesn't smell that bad so
i'm guessing you do that
and you light it and it heats it right
this is super stable i'm gonna get the
fire extinguisher
just be ready be ready
i'm gonna have a hot meal okay here we
go
three two one
burning very quickly i'm back
i'm going to lay it phosphorus down
strike this lay it in here sideways so
it's up against it very close at the
bottom
and then hope
[Music]
hello
did i do it oh i think i did it
oh did i do it oh wow
that's so cool am i supposed to like
stir it probably
well you know what maybe not that ain't
exactly stable that's so cool though
it's just a little fire you can smell it
the food or the chemical all right cool
i should probably say
this i'm a professional reviewer and i
know exactly what i'm doing at all times
so uh don't do this while this is
heating up i can always try some of
these other things
we got some kind of a dried fruit bar i
hope
oh that's not bad garlic apples and
stuff in it i actually like that a lot
i like that a lot better than some of
the fruit bars i've had i don't know
what's in it maybe not even fruit but i
like it i feel like this is some kind of
drink mix
definitely some kind of powder let me
get another cup
oh no what is it what's up
yeah i opened the lid
was i not supposed to oh
i've been instructed to not eat this
based on research that i'm doing it
completely wrong and apparently it can
create
some pretty bad stuff to put inside your
body so i'm not gonna eat that but i'm
gonna let it go because it smells good
it doesn't all right i'm assuming this
is some kind of a drink thing
if it's not then i'm very way off base
oh no it's just sugar is that just sugar
is this just sugar why would they just
have a packet of sugar
yeah it's got to be a drink mix looks
like a drink mix
it's got to be a drink mix right
that doesn't taste like anything what
did i just put in my glass
i don't know what is maybe applesauce
applesauce maybe oh no
oh no what is that what is that
what is that what is it
what is that that tastes like apples so
it's fascinating right it's a very
very very different approach cooking
with an open flame
these weird tin things as opposed to all
plastic pouches
some paste some kind of
whatever that is i don't trust that the
thing is like i
none of these are a recognizable food so
i don't know what to trust the only
thing i recognize is the crackers
and i think there's some like something
in there i think i might just rather try
the other one cold
i think this might be old what's this
supposed to be this is another powder
how many powders do you need what is
this
looks like flour what's the flour for
what's that flower
cocaine flour
cheese this is weird man this is weird
it's weird what is this it's another
powder it's more cheese
more cheese no
that's the drink mix i'll be back
but that begs the question if that was
the drink mix
what the hell did i put in that last cup
of water
what that's definitely a drink mix right
is the flame dying out
flames finally dying okay here we go
here we go here we go
yoinkus doinkus it doesn't smell bad
might be okay let me try the drink mix
first
not as good as tank i hate to say it but
that is not as good what is this
right i'm gonna try the food
have an ambulance on standby it doesn't
smell bad
it's warm too hey that's actually not
bad there's some kind of meat at the
bottom
it might be old who knows i don't know
hopefully i cook the
any bacteria out of it but it seemed to
be oh it's just
i definitely cooked this wrong it just
crushed it at the bottom burnt but the
top layer
that's okay much like the ravioli and
the last one the main dish
was actually the best part i'm not even
gonna bother trying this because i'm
this is taking way too long and i'm
running out of time and i've got so many
crackers and i don't i can't read it
but i have one more okay
i think this is out
[Music]
oh oh no oh boy
you don't tell us all about this okay
i'm gonna put a doily on here i'm gonna
put a doily on here
no one's ever gonna know about it okay
especially not amy okay cool we're good
last but not least maybe maybe least who
knows
boom the koreans so these are south
korean mres
they're smaller i don't think it's going
to take as long to go through them it's
odd that it's smaller because korean
meals usually have a lot more
dishes to them what's going on in here
spoons are
oh this is the worst spoons of the bunch
oh these spoons are awful
oh they're flim flames oh they're flim
flams
at least they don't break each other
they're probably equally as bad but ah
at least it's longer i gotta give it for
that
it's at least longer so there's a bit
more reach to it i'm okay with that
all right but these are korean mres
we've got
young shikhtan
so this is another flameless thing you
put
water in oh my god oh
hell yeah so it's it's literally just
bibimbap it's got like
uh dehydrated rice in there veggies of
some sort the instructions say
you take the packets out you fill water
to the line
okay so it's not a flameless thing you
need hot water cold water
30 minutes hot water 10 minutes all
right well i do have hot water i'm going
to add the hot water
okay and now 10 minutes on the clock
[Music]
you know what i appreciate the most
about this um is that even if it's a
military ration
it still has a lovely little cartoon
character on it just so you get a little
smile when you eat
you know that's what i really like about
it it's really nice also this is
so kogi which is beef
beef flavor gochujang which is the
chili paste bibimbap which is if you
haven't had bibimbap
i would recommend bibimbap it's good so
this is the gochujang
this is sesame oil which is just yeah
anything and look at that
easy cut i was having a hell of a time
with all these other ones
easy cut and this is impressive about it
because i don't know if this is the
standard korean
ration but this is really cool because
koreans are known as like the masters of
side dishes so i thought
that the ration might have it and i was
surprised when these are so small but it
makes sense right
it's all in one the country that's
really good at doing a lot of side
dishes but also they have this
lovely thing called bibimbap and if you
eat meat and pop it's basically just all
the leftovers they had from the meal
before you get rice you get bean sprouts
you get
some of the vegetables you put whatever
meat you had last night you add some
gochujang to it or some
like sesame oil or soy sauce whatever
you want to and you just
call it a bowl and you eat it all it's
delicious and warm too
uniformly warm like very warm i mean
obviously i had to boil my own water so
and there's no drink with this like
let's be frank i like the tang i didn't
like the whatever the russian
that one was but it's it was nice to
have a drink but at the same time
it's not necessary i mean you're just
trying to get a meal
the fact that you could make it with
cold water i don't imagine it would be
as good but
uh the fact that you can make it with
cold water and it takes 30 minutes you
know
it's not bad there goes my time so it
should be done
uh actually
[Applause]
oh
that actually smelled good and that rice
it was super like it looked like rice
crispy rice but it's actually fluffed up
quite a bit okay what do i have first
easy cut so it says let's see how easy
it'd be
that was an easy cut that was definitely
an easy cut
i like that okay and then the gochujang
give it some spice
you know that's that's the thing about
like korean food you know you had got to
jump to pretty much anything it
makes it infinitely better when in doubt
add heat right am i right everybody
mom am i right now the spoon let's see
if this lives up to oh that's fine
oh that works perfectly it's a little
flim flam
and minus points on the on the spoon but
hey that's it does the job it's doing
what it needs to do and apparently this
is 400 calories i think it's missing out
on a good bit of protein
but at the same time that smells good
now let's give it a try cheers
it's not the best bibimbap i've ever had
but it's still
really good there's no crackers that are
too hard there's no weird paste that i
don't know what it is there's no muffin
that's trying to be a muffin
it's just food it's good food if i was
just casually
like day-to-day life knew that i had a
packet of this that i could make at any
time
i would actually buy this i'm floored
that's actually good out of all these
koreans the best package right you just
add water
you just get a spoon you dig it right
yeah i mean you got your sauces but you
just
spoon water add sauce dig in done
easiest to go
less mess too there's no cleanup
everything else had a million cartons
as far as spoons go obviously the
american spoon
it's like our cars you know too big too
ornery too angry
but you kind of like it so that's it for
these mres i know there's many mres
around the world
i don't know if i'm gonna do a video
about them but this was a fun experiment
this was neat i've never had mres before
but in reality i guess the end of the
day they're just trying to be the best
instant food they can
and i love instant food with that being
said thank you everybody so much for
watching
uh if you've got other things you want
me to review let me know down in the
comments below i'm always open to
different suggestions and ideas
that's a lie i'm not but maybe i am
leave a like if you enjoyed this video
comment if you want to see more ring the
bell to be notified when these things
come again
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye